what's up y'all so as you may know you
probably have seen this and other
people's videos and [ __ ] but probably
not cause I'm trying to release it
before the [ __ ] asses but we're in
Vegas
on a company trip let me show you all a
couple things that I do it real quick
huh and y'all know I used to be a
professional pool player we are here to
relax have a little bit of fun and we're
gonna go eat at go-to Ramsay Pub & Grill
now that fool talks a lot of [ __ ] on TV
so I really want to see what the heck is
about because this food [ __ ] sucks on
the Walker replace it [ __ ] kick his
ass probably not just pretty buff we are
outside of Gordon Ramsay Pub robots walk
in remember if your food sucks I'm gonna
have a word with you it tastes like
chicken and snuffed I'm looking at this
Maine lobster and shrimp roll what I'm
very disappointing that because I mauled
us trip to the Maine lobster cheap much
Ramsay come see me to be honest with you
when I see him cook his food it looks
pretty [ __ ] amazing and I'm just like
I I think generally to like his knife
skills are pretty dope so I don't know
man I I think I would you know what I
thought let the mess pick my face I
probably would I'd probably let me spit
directly in my face
if you let them put two pieces of bread
on your face haha you are an idiot
sandwich I was looking for really easy
reference recipes before to like make em
home and I came across this recipe
called bangers and mash and I thought
it's not awesome then I come to find
it's just mashed potatoes covered with
sausages covered in gravy and I made it
at home and it's like the best like
hangover or like drinking kind of food
because it soaks up everything it is so
savory and salty it's just a really good
combination but when I saw it here I was
like dude I've never actually seen it on
the menu at a restaurant before
I think I'm gonna get it today but you
won't charge $27 for buttered chicken
that's Indian food no charge $20,000 for
Indian food Indian food is bomb but
that's known to be like cheap food
that's delicious
$27 you [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you're
gonna charge me $30 for Indian food as
an impoverished country [ __ ] you if you
told the Indian person that you're gonna
make $27 worst food you would have a
heart attack you're going to give me $30
for this you are [ __ ] crazy
[Music]
so for a couple of appetizers lemon we
got these um Navy kettle chip nachos as
corn beef cattle chip nachos it's pretty
[ __ ] good I'll give you a pass on
that and next we have calamari which
tastes like [ __ ] [ __ ] that's a pretty
good they're cheaters look at this it's
all red all the lobsters up here and it
makes it look like it's all like legit
oh man what's going on this Lobster
then you realize they cheat it all the
press ahead $18 pretty good would you
buy it again I love super many freaking
delicious so like I thought this bread
was really hard for me you touch it it's
kind of like crispy
it's really nice and fluffy I don't know
how its fluffy with us and this bread is
so cool cuz it has a little kick to it
[Music]
been here for 45 minutes just like ask
them advertisers were good they came out
pretty quick but that's about it
45 minutes I don't know Bouldin Ramsay
what's happening behind your kitchen
I'll tell you this your food is
delicious if it came out of a horse ass
[Music]
so I got a 14 ounce ribeye yes I'm not
counting macros here this weekend trying
to be relatively conscious about it but
I'm I'm lying to you right now
béarnaise sauce is delicious with steaks
beets poultry whatever you might get
with it's a butter sauce watch this [ __ ]
right here
fall in
okay that's not about schools I thought
it nice
the sauce here
good move on the lip
there's a dog the one that didn't used
on my own recipe was an actual British
banger and I didn't have access to a
British sausage bye-bye time sausages so
that made it taste different than this
and this is like a really basic sausage
actually and giant sausages have way
more spice to it a lot more complex
flavors is very basic better than
gorilla mole no door shuts a burger like
not even like oh my god the greatest
burger it's just like I'm gonna tell you
something holding your food is [ __ ] your
burger subpar it would be delicious if I
scraped it off the road and fed it to a
person without any tastebuds my steak
was fantastic I feel good it was a
grilled ribeye and apparently they
grilled it over an open fire with some
plain old wood chips so you can really
taste that the meat 430 bombers but the
burgers were very disappointing and
there's supposed to be a pub bar and
grill and if you can't make a good
burger Gordon I don't know what to tell
you and I'm gonna say it again
you charge somebody $27 for Indian food
what the [ __ ] golden
you did one good thing the game is free
Tupperware but me take oh thank you I
need these you're fantastic but your
burgers are still [ __ ]
I would eat your burger if I was lost on
an island only after I ate my own leg
but the steak was fantastic in
conclusion we are talking about a
restaurant that serves overly priced
food that I can't really say this that
good I haven't mind to go to the back of
the kitchen and talk to them as I
normally do and say who's gonna show you
what the [ __ ] were you thinking no but
in all honesty it was a the steak was
really good
it wasn't that I don't know it when you
go to a pumpin it will you expect their
burgers to be really amazing in a lot of
the stuff that I'm watching especially
on Kitchen Nightmares and he really
gives [ __ ] to people who make really
crappy burgers Gordon Lee burgers alone
that [ __ ] is not your skill absolutely
at all steak though with the Bearnaise
sauce [ __ ] good the [ __ ] fries with
a truffle friggin bomb a lot of people
might be ordering the wrong food that's
why they're giving this place like a
three or four three and a half star
rating or so but if you get the things
that are good here so just a steak or
something
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]